bonsoir à tous bienvenue voici les
titres de votre journal jacques chirac
renvoyé en correctionnel abus de
confiance détournement de fonds publics
c'est la sphère des emplois présumés
fictifs de la mairie de paris
une première dans l'histoire de la vème
république explications et réactions
dans un instant trente ans de prison
dont vingt de sûreté francis evrard
vient d'être condamné pour l'enlèvement
et le viol dennis en août 2007 la
perpétuité avait été requise contre le
pédophile récidiviste
air france a réceptionné son premier
airbus a380 la compagnie est la première
en europe à se doter du très gros
porteur premier vol commercial le 20
novembre prochain
les mots des ados sont parfois
difficiles à formuler mais ne relève pas
tous de la psychanalyse un médecin
généraliste a ouvert une consultation
spécialement destiné aux adolescents et
aux jeunes adultes
la technique n'est pas nouvelle mais
grâce au numérique elle opère sa
révolution la 3d investit les écrans de
cinéma
de plus en plus de salles s'équipent et
grâce à de simples lunettes séduit
petits et grands c'est donc une première
dans l'histoire de la vème république un
ancien président renvoyé devant un
tribunal correctionnel si le parquet n'a
pas fait appel dans les cinq jours
jacques chirac devra répondre d'abus de
confiance et de détournement de fonds
publics dans la sphère des emplois
présumés fictifs de la mairie de paris
lionel feierstein vers gênés travers
c'est une nouvelle qu'il redoutait
depuis des années à 77 ans jacques
chirac pourrait se retrouver sur le banc
des prévenus
la juge d'instruction xavière simeoni
contre l'avis du parquet vient de
demander son renvoi devant un tribunal
correctionnel pour abus de confiance et
détournement de fonds publics
son avocat l'a joint ce matin par
téléphone l'ancien chef d'état se dit
serein depuis qu'il a quitté l'elysée au
mois de mai 2007
ils savaient qu'ils répondraient aux
juges il a été mis en examen il ya
maintenant deux ans et il fait donc un
parcours de justiciables de droit commun
normal comme tous les français la sphère
des chargés de mission de la ville de
paris concerne 21 emplois dont certains
sont présumés fictifs pour une période
comprise entre 1992 et 1995
selon la juge d'instruction ses
collaborateurs qui ne travaillait pas à
la mairie ont été rémunérés en toute
illégalité par la ville des proches de
l'ancien maire en ont bénéficié comme
jean de gaulle le petit-fils du général
françois debré le frère de jean louis
debré ou encore marc blondel l'ancien
secrétaire général de force ouvrière
avait un garde du corps payé par la
mairie
depuis il a remboursé la ville c'était
pour l'organisation parce que c'était
une prise en charge dont nous avions
besoin que c'est bon c'est tout donc je
n'ai pas eu d'intérêt financier ni
personnel mais collectif dans cette
affaire sauf effectivement que ça nous
invitait de le payer en tout dix
personnes ont été renvoyées devant le
tribunal dont deux directeurs de cabinet
de jacques chirac michel roussin et rémy
chardon
deux hommes qui ont toujours affirmé
n'avoir fait qu'obéir aux ordres
le directeur de cabinet n'était ni
demandeurs al embauche lui contrôleurs
de la réalité ou de l'efficacité de ce
contrat qui lui demandait de signer ces
contrats jamais jacques chirac
il n'est pas exclu que le maire ait été
amenée lui même à apprécier
l'opportunité d'une embauche l'actuelle
mairie estime son préjudice à plusieurs
millions d'euros
en théorie jacques chirac encourt dix
ans de prison et 150 mille euros damende
le parquet a cinq jours pour faire appel
la juge simeoni n'a donc pas tenu compte
des réquisitions du parquet qui
réclamait un non lieu général
elle estime qu' après douze ans
d'immunité pénale jacques chirac est un
justiciable comme les autres et que les
charges qui pèsent sur lui justifie son
renvoi en correctionnelle valérie astruc
elle est la première juge d'instruction
a renvoyé un ancien président devant le
tribunal c'est comment nous fait
vraiment et comme un autre je réponds je
vis aujourd'hui
peut-être pas tout à fait comme les
autres mais depuis qu'il a quitté
l'elysée l'ancien président de la
république est redevenu un justiciable
comme un autre
le premier à avoir essayer d'entendre
jacques chirac c'était eric halphen le
juge enquête alors sur la sphère des hlm
de paris et décide en mars 2001 de
convoquer le président de la république
et comme à l'époque la constitution
était muette
je me suis dit que rien n'empêchait un
juge de convoquer comme témoin le
président de la république jacques
chirac refuse alors de venir chez le
juge
et c'est justice tous ceux qui
m'attaquent sachant très bien que je ne
peux pas me défendre que je ne peux pas
mécontent du que je ne peux pas porter
plainte en diffamation peuvent dire tout
ce qu'ils veulent en toute sérénité et
sans courir aucun risque
la question du statut pénal du président
est posée elle sera défini en 2007 par
le conseil constitutionnel le chef de
l'état est à l'abri des juges pendant
l'exercice de son mandat mais il peut
rendre des comptes après la
démonstration définitive de ce que dans
le système constitutionnel tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui les présidents de la
république bénéficie bien d'une immunité
mais pas d'une impunité s'y lie à lui à
les poursuivre on peut normalement les
poursuivre selon le droit commun
une fois qu'ils ont quitté l'elysée donc
le principe d'égalité dans la justice
est tout à fait respecté l'ancien
président de la république pourrait donc
être jugé pour des actes commis par le
maire de paris il ya plus de 15 ans et
les réactions à présent si pour certains
le renvoi de jacques chirac en
correctionnelle est légitime il arrive
bien tard au point de s'interroger sur
sa nécessité globalement à droite comme
à gauche les commentaires sont très
mesurés alix bouilhaguet on a connu
nicolas sarkozy plus babar cet après
midi à bruxelles
il a pesé ses mots pour commenter le
renvoi en correctionnelle de jacques
chirac
un principe affiché la séparation des
pouvoirs s'il ya bien quelqu'un qui ne
peut présenter le moindre commentaire
c'est moi
quelles que soient par ailleurs les
sentiments que je peux avoir un
l'endroit de jacques chirac
guère plus loquace sur l'ancien
président les chiraquiens de la première
heure rares à prendre la parole
on aurait aimé effectivement voilà
qu'ils puissent sereinement se consacrer
à ce qui est maintenant sa passion sa
raison d'être
la justice ont déçu autrement dont acte
sur son blog jean pierre raffarin
l'ancien premier ministre de jacques
chirac estime que l'homme ne mérite pas
cela certains proches sont au contraire
soulagé
cette espèce de de boulet qu'il traîne
depuis des années sur les affaires dites
de la mairie de paris ben c'est pas mal
que le l'accès soit une fois pour toutes
crever pour les bons sentiments il faut
plutôt se tourner vers les socialistes à
leurs yeux un renvoi légitime mais
tardif il ya un malaise chacun le
comprend malaise de voir un ancien
président de la république ainsi mis
devant une situation inédite et puis il
ya un malaise parce que c'est des
affaires qui remonte à très loin d'une
certaine façon renvoyé à l'ancien
président de la république en
correctionnelle c'est une mauvaise image
qu'on le fait une mauvaise image pour la
france quant aux verts noël mamère
jacques chirac renvoyé devant un
tribunal rien de plus logique d'y graver
au bandonéon s'explique s'il en est dans
une république bananière donc j'entends
les cris d'orfraie qui sont lancés par
certains et en aval que chirac
s'expliquera à 77 ans l'ancien président
est rattrapé par la justice au sommet de
sa popularité
ce renvoi court circuite la publication
de ses mémoires prévue vendredi prochain
francis evrard condamné à 30 ans de
réclusion criminelle assortis d'une
période de sûreté de 20 ans pour
l'enlèvement et le viol dennis en août
le verdict est tombé il ya deux heures
bonsoir aurélien guillemin vous êtes en
direct de la cour d'assises de douai
le pédophile récidiviste échappe donc à
la peine maximale qui avait pourtant été
requise
oui effectivement ce n'est pas la peine
maximale mais c'est une peine de mise à
l'écart 20 ans de sûreté ça signifie que
francis evrard ne pourra bénéficier
d'aucune mesure d'aménagement de peine
avant l'âge de 83 ans 83 ans est un
minimum
par ailleurs la cour a été prudente elle
précise qu'un suivi socio judiciaire
aura lieu pendant 20 années
supplémentaires en cas de remise en
liberté de francis evrard donc ce sont
des précautions qui soulage qui rassure
le père dinis que je vous propose
d'écouter maintenant quand même
satisfait et je pense qu'enis pas
contents aussi parce que pour moi il
mourra en prison quoi vous c'est
d'ailleurs un petit garçon bah je vais
dire qu'on a quand même gagné bachas on
lui se prend pour un super man parce que
il me dit que grâce à lui des autres
enfants ils vont être sauvés
donc là quand je vais lui dire que comme
à gagner qui ressortira pu pendant très
très très très longtemps
bah il va être très très content là se
prend encore pour son pour eux le
superman des enfants
voilà c'est une page qui se tourne pour
toute une famille mais vous imaginez
aussi que pour réunis il ya seulement
sept ans c'est un long travail de
reconstruction qui commence comme pour
toutes les victimes de viol aurélia
guima en direct des assises de doigts
merci alors ce procès aura aussi pointé
de nombreux dysfonctionnements de la
juge d'application des peines qui n'a
pas été remplacé pendant ses vacances
aux médecins de la prison qui a prescrit
du viagra à francis evrard juste avant
sa sortie les défaillances de la justice
en matière de récidive ont été mises en
évidence
aurélia guillemin nicolas aubert pervers
manipulateur
le diagnostic des experts est sans appel
alors aurait-on pu le soigner plus tôt
après trois procès neuf condamnations et
35 ans de prison certains le disent
aujourd'hui incurables il n'a pas été
très désireux
l'idée accessible aux soins comme tout
le monde mais à condition de le vouloir
le problème des pervers c'est qu'ils
veulent pas évoluer tant qu'ils veulent
pas évoluer il faut parce qu'une
division mais le procès a aussi mis en
lumière les carences dans le suivi
judiciaire de francis evrard avant sa
dernière libération
ce médecin lui prescrit du viagra alors
qu'il est incarcéré pour viol sur
mineure un peu plus tard lors de sa
sortie la surveillance tarde à se mettre
en place parce qu'on est en période de
vacances
autant de dysfonctionnements qui de
l'avis de tous devaient être évité il
n'y a pas 1 400 personnes nuit il y en a
très peu et on doit avoir une attention
tout à fait particulière urgente
immédiate est manifestement sept skins
c'est pas passé et je pense que d'une
certaine façon on a participé aussi à ce
qui s'est passé le 15 août
nous disons que c'est une responsabilité
de l'état qui ne permet pas au service
de l'application des peines de
fonctionner de la même manière tous les
mois de l'année une plainte à venir et
un constat sur lequel tout le monde
s'accorde l'insuffisance des moyens de
la justice pour prendre en charge
efficacement les condamner les plus
lourds et lutter contre la récidive
il est clair que quand un service
pendant les vacances se retrouve
dépourvu de fonctionnaires les n'a pas
suffisamment de magistrats bas il est
clair qu'il ya forcément des erreurs qui
peuvent se commettre c'est ça la réalité
lui a tout avoué et risque fort de
passer le reste de sa vie derrière les
barreaux
mais pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'autres
récidivistes comme francis evrard il
faudra tirer toutes les leçons de cette
affaire
un drame à toulouse ce matin un employé
de l'entreprise de transport ups fait
irruption dans les locaux armé d'un
fusil de chasse il a ouvert le feu sur
le patron et son fils vraisemblablement
à l'origine de ce double homicide un
différend professionnel entre les trois
hommes
le tueur présumé et sa compagne sont ce
soir en garde à vue l'avancé des 27 au
sommet de bruxelles paris et berlin
soutiendront le même candidat à la
présidence de l'union le président
tchèque ne poserait plus de condition à
la ratification du traité de lisbonne
françois beaudonnet bonsoir vous êtes
sur place il s'en est passé des choses
aujourd'hui d'autant que les vingt-sept
ont aussi progressé sur le climat à mine
même si ce fut compliqué oui
effectivement est d'ailleurs ce sommet
européen s'achève sur un accord a minima
sur le climat alors ce n'est pas l'échec
total que l'on pouvait craindre encore
ce matin les dirigeants des vingt-sept
ont réussi à trouver une position
commune sur copenhague mais ils n'ont
pas de quoi sabler le champagne
loin de là parce qu'ici et bien les 27
n'ont pas voulu ou pas su dire combien
il allait mettre sur la table pour
sauver le climat alors en revanche le
traité de lisbonne lui semble
définitivement sur les rails il entrera
en vigueur vraisemblablement le 1er
décembre prochain c'est dans un mois
parce que la république tchèque a obtenu
ce qu'elle souhaitait alors du coup
l'europe va devoir se choisir un
président du conseil européen et ce soir
il est presque certain que ce ne sera
pas tony blair même nicolas sarkozy ne
le soutient plus près ce que certains
également que ce ne sera pas un leader
charismatique une personnalité mais
plutôt un simple secrétaire général et
c'est dommage parce que si c'est ce
profil qui est choisi et bien l'europe
aura peut-être manqué une occasion
unique d'exister sur la scène
internationale merci françois pour ces
précisions direct de bruxelles et
j'ajoute que les dirigeants européens
ont décidé de lancer un projet de vols
charters financés par l'union pour
l'expulsion vers leur pays d'origine des
migrants en situation irrégulière c'est
une initiative française dont l'étude
est prise en compte malgré des réserves
de la commission européenne
c'est un privilège dont bénéficient les
clubs sportifs professionnels le droit à
l'image collectif pourrait bientôt
disparaître
ce dispositif permet actuellement au
club de voir leurs charges sociales
alléger les clubs craignent que
l'amendement qu'ils suppriment soit
définitivement adopté par le parlement
et que les joueurs s'exile à l'étranger
grégory naboulet olivier martinez serait
ce la fin d'une période dorée pour le
sport français
hier à l'assemblée nationale les députés
ont voté la fin du droit à l'image
collectif des sportifs professionnels
le défi c'est cet avantage fiscal permet
au club d'alléger leurs charges sociales
sur 30% du salaire des joueurs exemple
le salaire moyen d'un joueur de ligue 1
et de 45000 euros
actuellement le club ne paye des charges
sociales que sur 31 1500 euros soit 70 %
du salaire sur les 30% restants le club
est exonéré
un privilège qui coûte cher à l'état 95
millions d'euros selon la cour des
comptes
moi je ne veux pas désavantager
quiconque
je dis simplement qu'il ya un certain
nombre de spécificités qui pouvait se
justifier notre époque où notre pays
était riche
maintenant nous connaissons des
difficultés il faut les remettre en
cause la possible suppression du droit à
l'image sème la panique dans le monde du
sport
tous dénoncent une mesure démagogique
les footballeurs craignent pour leur
compétitivité sur la scène européenne
les rugbymen pour leur santé financière
il est évident et je vous donne rendez
vous si la loi est appliquée au 30 juin
il y aura cinq six clubs de rugby qui ne
seront plus là en top 14 c'est une
certitude qu'ils pourront pas supporter
ce cap
alors c'est simple si on supprime le
délice et les joueurs repartiront
d'autres partiront plus vite et à ce
moment là la fiscalité baissera en
france je crois qu'on aura tout perdu
la crainte du monde sportif
professionnel est clair voir partir pour
partir les meilleurs joueurs à
l'étranger
leur dernier espoir que le sénat rejette
l'amendement qui supprime le droit à
l'image
le match est loin d'être terminée c'est
la première compagnie aérienne en europe
à se doter du très gros porteur d'airbus
air france a réceptionné aujourd'hui à
roissy son premier a380 d'une capacité
de 538 passagers le double environ des
autres appareils
celui ci permettrait de réaliser 15
millions d'euros d'économies par an et
par avion
julien bon nombre emmanuel bex sont
montés à bord de cette prouesse
technologique doublée d'une arme anti
crise c'est une livraison très attendu
le premier a380 aux couleurs d'air
france
c préparez vous pour le décollage merci
et à nouveau je vous souhaite un
excellent voyage avec des collages les
usines d'assemblage d'airbus à hambourg
en allemagne
carpe sur roissy charles de gaulle un
vol inaugural pour 300 invités premier
constat des passagers le silence à bord
on a quand même quatre moteurs qui ont
été gérés mis en action pour arracher
environ 400 tonnes de soles et on n'a
pas entendu le bruit des moteurs
côté innovation ce plafond lumineux qui
reproduit lever du jour où coucher du
soleil pour les neuf passagers de la
première pas d'ostentatoire des
fauteuils club transformable en libre et
cette cabine privative pour se changer
à l'étagé supérieur voici la galerie
trois écrans diffusent des images d'une
exposition temporaire au louvre la
classe affaires propose 80 sièges
complètement inclinable en tout six bars
ont été créés un concept qui plaît
c'est un espace de convivialité c'est un
moment de régulation
fait partie
plaisir du voyage pour les 4 149 places
de la classe éco siège légèrement
agrandie écran tactile ports usb et
possibilité de chatter avec d'autres
passagers
un nouvel espace de travail a aussi été
mis en place pour l'équipage
l'aménagement en ce qui concerne
également les espaces de travail pour
moi
habituellement tout ça pour uniquement 5
cm de large pour travailler l'avion 3,80
m cet a380 ses larmes anti cri d'air
france un avion qui consomme 20% - un
avion deux en un un avion de 538 places
et en place deux avions qui offrait
ensemble 538 places dont il n'y a pas de
croissance au camp temps de crise ou
diminuer beaucoup
et vous vous êtes toujours à la même
capacité donc c'est un outil efficace
avant d'entrer en service le 20 novembre
prochain entre paris et new york
l'a380 a été baptisé par les jets d'eau
des pompiers de roissy charles gaulle
air france on a commandé au total douze
exemplaires
en avril dernier nous vous avions fait
partager le quotidien de ces familles
chinoises dont l'enfant avait disparu
victimes de réseaux de trafiquants ont
bien depuis le gouvernement a lancé une
campagne pour tenter d'endiguer ce drame
et la police vient de démanteler un
réseau de trafiquants d'enfants pascal
golomer et s'il vient journaux
correspondant en chine ont assisté vous
allez le voir des retrouvailles
émouvantes
ces images ont envahi les écrans de la
télévision chinoise aujourd'hui images
de retrouvailles entre des parents et
leurs enfants
si aux longues enlevés il ya cinq ans la
police se charge de la mise en scène
avec soin et tant pis pour l'intimité de
ces moments difficiles
hermès a valu à penser à nous retrouver
may hamm a que vous avez vous manqué
soit notre enfant comprendra mieux quand
tu seras grand
si yao longue et l'un des soixante
enfants dont les visages sont présentés
au public depuis mardi dans l'espoir que
leurs proches les reconnaisse
officiellement 2000 enfants volés ont
été récupérés ces derniers mois la
plupart avaient été vendues par des
gangs à des familles en mal d'héritier
beaucoup ont pu être rapidement
identifiés grâce notamment à une banque
de données adn
la seule solution efficace beaucoup
d'enfants ont été revendus plusieurs
fois où il était trop jeune au moment de
leur enlèvement pour se souvenir de leur
famille d'origine
ces retrouvailles c'est le résultat
d'une campagne nationale lancée en
grande pompe en avril dernier pour
démanteler les réseaux de trafiquants
d'enfants
enfin pourrait-on dire en avril
justement nous avions rencontré des
parents qu'ils recherchaient
désespérément leurs enfants volés
d'origine modeste il souffrait alors de
l'indifférence des autorités on leur
interdisait même de se réunir pour
sensibiliser l'opinion
aujourd'hui il espère que cette campagne
spectaculaire de la police marque un
tournant
il y a encore tant d'enfants a retrouvé
il est 20 heures 18 ans à suivre dans
votre journal nous irons en consultation
chez un médecin généraliste qui s'est
spécialisé dans les mots des adolescents
la vente de ces petites pilules s'est
banalisé pourtant les compléments
alimentaires ne font pas l'unanimité
chez les médecins
et puis la 3d s'invite au cinéma
révolution numérique oblige le relief
semble être l'avenir du septième art les
problèmes des adolescents ne trouvent
pas toujours de réponse avec les
psychologues il est souvent plus facile
pour eux de parler à un médecin ainsi
une généraliste a ouvert une
consultation spécialement dédié aux ados
sophie mais elle guillaume michel c'est
d'être parti justement de chez mes
parents j'ai répercuter tout ça sur la
nourriture
oui l'édifice voilà anorexie boulimie
léonore souffre de ce qu'on appelle des
troubles du comportement alimentaire
comment on peut le comprendre ça mais je
sais pas j'ai tellement été couronné
comme j'étais petit et que du coup j'ai
eu un manque énorme et le fait elle est
partie seule comme ça peut-être pas
forcément prêtes
ben voila j'ai cherché quelque chose
auquel je pourrais me réfugier vous vous
sentez capable de jeter la balance moi
oui si on fait ce n'est pas le poids qui
m'intéresse plus l'image ouais le reflet
que j'ai une glace alors envoyé quoi un
reflet qui les bacs
les routes sont mal être c'est à cette
spécialiste des adolescents et des
jeunes adultes qu elle le confie une
consultation tout en échange qui n'est
pas une consultation de psy et qui ne se
traduit presque jamais par une
prescription à l'adolescence la
consultation pour fatigue ou pour des
plein flou j'ai mal aux vents du mal à
la tête
bon ça a toujours un sens qui est le
sens de ce moment d'hésitation à se
prendre en charge à devenir grand qu'on
traduit à travers son corps par des
plaintes
si on se contente de soigner la plainte
et de renvoyer avec du spasfon fait pas
notre travail
le médecin va aussi servir de trait
d'union entre les parents et les jeunes
y compris pour des troubles qui semblent
anodins bond pierce une nette de votre
maman est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que depuis le début de l'année
indépendamment de ce problème de notes
il ya un problème de comportement à
l'école c'est juste que je voudrais vous
répondez un peu aux français oui la
façon dont un est de l'essence peut se
comporter de façon bruyante à l'école
quand c'est trop répétitif et quand ça
le met hors jeu
c'est souvent un masque et derrière
c'est un adolescent qui a fait bien
mathilde repartira avec la volonté
d'être moins dissipée et d'avoir un
meilleur bulletin est pour elle et pas
seulement pour ses parents un français
sur cinq ans consomment au moins une
fois par an pour maigrir bronzés ou
avoir de beaux cheveux et pourtant les
compléments aliments
sont sous haute surveillance l'afssa
agence française de sécurité sanitaire
des aliments vient de mettre en place un
dispositif de vigilance c'est inédit en
europe les effets indésirables devront
être systématiquement signalés
marie-pierre samitier vincent barras
toutes ces pilules miracles représente
un marché juteux d'un milliard d'euros
les français les consomment de plus en
plus et sans méfiance
ça donne beaucoup de son nom beaucoup de
tonus ma famille mon consommant beaucoup
de ces journées on en mange donc les
yeux fermés et pourtant les compléments
alimentaires peuvent avoir des effets
indésirables selon une étude américaine
le bêta carotène augmenterait le risque
de cancer du poumon chez le fumeur et
vitamines nature fera taire action entre
médicaments et suppléments alimentaires
peut être dangereuse ceux qui
contiennent des antioxydants
c'est à dire des anti vieillissement par
exemple les antioxydants il faut en
effet faire attention et au dos et aux
conseils donnés chez des gens qui ont
des pathologies lourdes avec des
traitements de chimiothérapie par
exemple et consommer trop de vitamine
est également risquée pour la santé
ainsi trop de vitamine c sévère au long
cours ça peut devenir au contraire proxy
dans ce délire ça peut altérer l'état de
vos artères donc ça peut au contraire
accélérer le processus de vieillissement
cellulaire
ce n'est pas du tout le but recherch
initialement évidemment alors ce
dispositif de vigilance va répertorier
les problèmes rencontrés par les
consommateurs car certains accidents
graves ont été rapportés
il s'agit effectivement de voir comment
les français consomment ces compléments
alimentaires et si effectivement
l'augmentation de la consommation induit
des effets indésirables
il se montre dans leurs plus beaux
atours toutefois selon la répression des
fraudes 12% de ces produits présentent
des anomalies et affiche une publicité
mensongère
emmaüs à 60 ans près de 4000 bénévoles
et compagnons se sont réunis aujourd'hui
au zénith sa part et pour fêter
l'anniversaire de l'association créée
par l'abbé pierre c'est en 1949
depuis sa naissance au lendemain de la
guerre donc à neuilly plaisance
l'association agit sans relâche contre
la grande pauvreté
laetitia legendre
rebecca benbarek arnaud jacques derniers
préparatifs pour les compagnons de la
communauté emmaüs de neuilly plaisance
qui fête les 60 ans du mouvement avec un
seul mot d'ordre aider les gens chez des
gens ont besoin et du tout le monde le
sait dix fois bien aussi a été choisi et
metz je pense c'est la seule solution
alternative
la seule utopie en fait de la deuxième
moitié du xxème siècle qui est toujours
en vie direction le zénith de paris où
4000 compagnons amis d'emmaüs sont
réunis pour fêter leur vision de la
solidarité
et toujours cette émotion quand retentit
la voix de leurs formateurs
rien ne le retient si tu voulais venir
mais à aider les autres pour chacun un
petit cadeau d'anniversaire un béret
noir comme un clin d'oeil au père comme
les anciens l'appelle encore
une chaîne de solidarité qui ne cède pas
avec le poids des années
hélas pour la baie d'hyères il est
toujours là pour nous le vin être là
aujourd'hui ça veut dire de faire partie
de cette famille et moi il m'a eu ma
famille ma deuxième famille n'ait pas eu
emmaüs et la matière je m'en fiche un
après-midi en chansons
olivia ruiz ya mme skalli font vibrer
tour à tour le coeur des chiffonniers
dont les combats sont toujours
d'actualité peut-être que ce soir si une
personne dix personnes sept personnes
ont une réflexion sur cette journée là
c'est c'est quelque part y anime les
plus grandes stars qu'elle est portée ne
sont pas dire mais si jamel mais plutôt
l'abbé pierre et soeur emmanuelle paix à
leurs armes des compagnons fier de vivre
du fruit de leur travail qui compte
prolonger cet anniversaire avec des
journées portes ouvertes dans les
communautés jusqu'à la mi novembre
la flamme des jeux olympiques d'hiver
qui se dérouleront du 12 au 28 février
prochain à vancouver est arrivée
aujourd'hui à victoria dans l'ouest du
canada regarder à bord d'un avion
militaire
le maire de vancouver est descendu en
portant une lampe de mineur abritant la
flamme qui va partir maintenant pour un
parcours de 45 1000 km à travers tout le
pays
la 3d s'invite au cinéma cette technique
qui existe depuis longtemps bien sûr
mais elle est remise au goût du jour
grâce à la révolution numérique de plus
en plus de salles s'équipent entrée dans
le grand écran grâce à de simples
lunettes est une idée bien entendu qui
séduit petits et grands jean francois
monier jean-marie lequertier est à
présent et layton mais bon lunettes
c'est aux données la troisième
révolution de la courte histoire du
cinéma est elle en marche
va-t-on regarder les films de cette
façon
après le parlant et la couleur dans les
années 30 place au relief la technique
existe depuis les années 50 mais les
films reste est anecdotique avec des
productions sans grand intérêt
mais avec l'arrivée du numérique le
relief a fait un bond en avant ces
derniers temps et les succès populaires
semblent au rendez vous et c'est super
en france est un groupe familial qui a
été le premier à investir massivement
sur ces 400 salles équipées en numérique
200 leçon pour la 3d le troisième
exploitant français veut offrir aux
spectateurs une large place aux films en
relief tous les studios américains et
même certains réalisateurs français que
j'ai croisé dernièrement travaille à
l'écriture déjà pour penser un film en
3d non plus on va dire ou numérisés ou
masteriser ou autres ils pensent
vraiment dès l'écriture au film en 3d or
c'est ça l'avenir et pour le relief le
groupe a choisi la technique dite
passive avec des lunettes légères et pas
très cher pour l'exploitant mais qui
nécessite de transformer les salles de
cinéma
côté cabine on place un petit écran à
cristaux liquides devant l'objectif
côté salle c'est ni plus ni moins le
remplacement de la toile par un écran
métallisé
coût de l'opération 70000 euros pour une
salle équipée en relief
chez mk2 c'est l'autre technique dite
active qui a été choisi pas de
changement d'écran mais les cristaux
liquides sont dans les lunettes plus
lourdes et plus coûteuses et qu il faut
absolument rendre à la fin de la séance
alors on a bien essayé de vous montrer
l'effet du relief sur votre écran de
télévision
sans succès en plein débat sur la
piraterie et sachant que la plupart des
films sont avant tout copier directement
dans les salles
l'industrie du cinéma il trouve pour
l'instant son compte il est impossible
de capter cette image 3d simple donc ils
auront l'image telle qu'on la voit sans
les lunettes et c'est ça qui sera
transcrit sur le dvd ou sur les
moniteurs ou sur internet
tout semble bien parti pour la 3d mais à
regarder de plus près avec les bonnes
lunettes tout n'est pas aussi clair la
production d'un film en relief coûte
plus cher qui va payer les producteurs
les exploitants
aujourd'hui la sortie d'un nouveau film
se fait au cas par cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que le surcoût d'une place de
cinéma en relief varie de 1 à 3 euros
et ce n'est pas toujours très bien
compris j'ai payé sur internet de 40
euros pour cinq classes et j'ai droit de
nos héros de supplément c'est pas très
grave si nous aurons sus commercialement
inacceptable sur 5500 salles en france
seulement 5 % sont équipés pour le
relief de nombreux films sont proposés
aujourd'hui à la fois en deux et trois
dimensions
preuve encore d'une certaine hésitation
mais tout le monde s'accorde à dire que
la sortie d'avatar entièrement dédié au
relief et au budget colossal de 300
millions de dollars va peut-être faire
entrer de septième art dans la troisième
dimension
avant de refaire votre journal je vous
en rappelle l'une des principales
informations jacques chirac renvoyé en
correctionnelle c'est une première dans
l'histoire de la vème république
c'est la sphère des emplois présumés
fictifs de la mairie de paris
le parquet qui réclamait un non lieu
général a cinq jours pour faire appel
fonte de quoi l'ancien président de la
république devra répondre d'abus de
confiance et de détournement de fonds
publics
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
avec isabelle martinet 20h35 ne manquez
pas nicolas le floch
je vous donne rendez vous demain dès 13h
pour l'information et à 13h15 pour votre
magazine vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur france 2 à demain
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr